olá a todos pessoal aqui quem fala é o
lugar que sejam muito bem vindos e mais
um vídeo e os estragos de que ninguém né
não
bom eu tenho ler os vossos comentários
de vocês pediram por série e continua a
atacar que faz mais ainda que estão indo
às ruas não disseram hoje eu gosto de
imaginar que sempre que eu acho que sou
bastante gostoso até bom
estamos aqui noite dois porque já
jogamos a primeira nessa gente ok
estamos aqui no quarto ano o que cada
novo que o tal eo macaco outra vez e eu
já não me lembro como é que cheguei
estou agora fundo do armário falou
qualquer coisa e não possuem o inglês
dela a jesus ainda cantar e cantar
o game ainda que houve qualquer coisa eu
acho que nesta noite que vai pôr ciro
leonor maria eu não sei mas nunca por
cima e cocaína 22 o papa
eu já ia dizer que estava tudo tranqüilo
quem é que é a minha mãe eu posso ter o
telefone não posso sair preciso lavar
champanhe a atriz né
2 outra vez meu eu não sei o que
aconteceu mas quando o game por silvio
jogo super completo homem sério e xampu
a contar as histórias sério o dólar cair
cala a boca e não quero saber como é que
o tão decantado sabe que isso é pouco é
por si um xale nada demais muito tentado
extrair vara que tomar cuidado porque
população chera e só pode ser para me
distrair prova que me apanhar quando eu
estiver à espera nem a janela tranquilo
com dilação tranquilo porta tranqüilo é
mario tranquilo eu acho que era um sapo
no chelsea também aí já não saí já não
sei se os shoppings funcionam eo ufms
bateria fiquei sem bater e apanhar a
filha lá isso vai vai
o que eu estava fazendo basta cana como
é que conseguiu entrar dentro lado basta
que é nessa e sim eu conseguir ver se
estava tudo fechado e eu estava lá
embaixo porque porque e único landa a
deus ao anjo sujos jesus ajuda me neste
momento definir se num ai ai ai um
palhaço toc toc um palhaço entre o meu
deus eu vou estar posta cana será a if
you também vai embora porque está um
pouco
já sei onde topo leão sueli que está
aquilo cuidado brut muito ao time temos
que ficar atentos a janela vai por ser
na próxima vez na janela eu sair não
terá portas à união uma manhã ou só
próximos quatro ou cinco vezes no
passado e cantar para mário jesus
eu não tô nem aí porque ficou mais curto
repente porque ficou acertado ainda que
o fone que está ligada à história a
jesus
o ponto de embarque ou faz parte do
lobby dos memes anormal extra
aquilo é o sapo
ai meu coração era o salto que eu fosse
um bicho homem
a ampla está muito escura que ai ai ai
eu tô eu entrou conseguiu entrar pela
ventilação e agora é que eu faço e agora
o que eu faço me envolvi com essa cara
mas vai estar já sair
ai ai nova trilha que o youtube xavier
lembra uma ventilação
a itália o corpo não o coruja está nada
de instrumento vai lá para o bastante
sai van
porque confiam porque confia um dos 11
ae
o rio ganhou a bota faca na bota faca
a ventilação já a meta como assim já
está aberta mas ainda agora com sua vez
um é meia noite 40 poço que 40 segundos
e esta [ __ ] já está aberta - como é que
é possível agora vou ter que olhar
sempre podem lução não é porque sou
viana quinto foi da bifana ligou nem nos
comentários e estas coisas do palácio de
corujas dos sapos xerém de como esses
são pistas e o tufão também a yoko pêra
pêra pêra onde é total porque é isto um
gesto para o leste a eu é um macaco né
então chama num evento é o vento vai
embora é para votar basta conversar
pilhas e pilhas ou não não há pilhas
vamos lá pra cima
ainda bem que o meu como é possível eu
estava lá em cima e isso é mentira eu
sou 15 da manhã falta uma foi embora e
ainda tem dois pauzinhos nutria e buscar
muito bem isso mas eu já tô pronto eu
sou eu por ser mais uma ou duas vezes
aqui dentro e vou conseguir ganhar isto
há nó ano ela só mais uma pedra o que é
que uma televisão
ai meu deus janela prejudicado por isso
cavaco fosse moran palavra lá faz um bis
continuar mas manhã destaca que o tempo
é o que podia
ai meu deus meu deus ai ai vou passar e
consegui passar
então é isso pessoal vamos ficar por
aqui com espírito para que vocês tenham
estado finalmente conseguimos passar
esta noite dois que sim eu vou fazer uma
série de jogos quiserem que eu noite 3
joga com os óculos ridículos os
comentários também se vocês querem e é
isso que vou falar que tudo isto fique
bem e até a próxima